all right the supreme court rules that
by the body administration can repeal
the trump era remain in mexico policy
which many say is necessary to secure
our southern border
the supreme court has helped set the
stage for the incentivization and
decriminalization immigration and now
joe biden wants his dhs to be able to
grant citizenship to people that have
legally entered our country fox news
contributor laura trump joins us now
laura what's your reaction to the
supreme court ruling
well obviously i think a lot of
conservatives and quite frankly people
who love this country believe in its
safety i'm sure a lot of folks on the
southern border on those border states
were not thrilled with this decision but
i think a lot of people can appreciate
the supreme court was following the law
here and and it is not their job
ultimately to protect our southern
border that is the job of the biden
administration to ensure that we don't
have illegal immigrants pouring over our
southern border now the the sad part
about this is that you heard it there
that's exactly right we are now going to
see i'm sure so many more people i mean
we've already had record numbers coming
over the southern border it is only
going to further incentivize people to
come here because they know now that
that policy is totally gone it's not
coming back and i think whenever you
take a look at things
and you look at the fact that the biden
administration hasn't been enforcing the
laws on our southern border and they
were so eager to get rid of a policy
like this remain in mexico policy which
really did a great job of deterring
people from coming here
it only further proves that not only are
they condoning illegal immigration but
they are encouraging it to happen within
the biden administration we know it's
dangerous for the people who are making
that journey coming here we saw the 53
people dead in the back of that truck a
third of women are sexually assaulted on
this journey north to our southern
border
it's something we should never be
encouraging unfortunately i think that's
ultimately the effect and the impact
that this decision is going to have it's
not going to be great for america it's
not going to be great for the immigrants
trying to illegally come here yeah maybe
it'll spur congress to codify border
security maybe not we'll see all right
let's turn to this house democrats are
pushing a trans bill of rights ahead of
the midterm elections let's take a look
at what the bill would have it would
have a guarantee it would guarantee the
right to an abortion allow students to
join sports teams aligning with their
gender identity that's men and women
sports and expand access to gender
affirming medical care laura what do you
think about this
well look i i don't think that there's
anyone that disagrees with every
american being treated equally and
fairly and respectfully but then you see
joey like you just outlined so many of
the the items that are contained within
this and obviously that does not reflect
the sentiments i think of most americans
and quite frankly at a time in america
where you have people struggling just to
make ends meet and get by the fact that
our elected officials are focused on
something like this which is such a
small percentage of our population the
trans community um it kind of is
frustrating i think to so many people to
think why aren't they focused on doing
things to fix the problems that are are
you know
part of our day-to-day lives like gas
prices and inflation and etc instead of
focusing on things like this so i think
there is a real frustration out there
that this administration and a lot of
leaders in washington dc are not
representing the vast majority of us and
doing things that are going to help us
out there in our day-to-day lives
unfortunately we have about 20 seconds
left but you have such a beautiful
family i just want to know how you're
celebrating the 4th of july this weekend
well we're doing what a lot of people
are doing we're we're going to be doing
a big barbecue and unfortunately i think
everybody's going to be paying a little
more despite what you heard last year
from the biden administration but we're
going to celebrate together we're really
looking forward to truth uh have a great
weekend thank you so much for joining us
as always on a friday we so appreciate
it fourth guys i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilny and i'm ainsley earhart and click
here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis